is this a moment of triumph and rebirth
for the Tory party or the beginning of
the end we have with us Lord Hetal time
former Tory Deputy Prime Minister and
now one of the parties both scathing
critics overexpressing policy or tears
on time thank you for joining us this
morning thank you now you have an op-ed
in The Sunday Times this morning along
with the Betty Boothroyd in it you talk
about brexit and no deal breaks it being
the most grotesque act of national
self-harm committed in peacetime by a
British government do you think that's a
little bit OTT no I don't I think you
win your headlines revealed exactly the
situation perhaps you should have added
you certainly should have added the fact
that the union of the United Kingdom
itself is at risk because polls are now
showing in Scotland but the economy is
stalled inflation is rising and the
pound is in serious difficulties and
threatened to get worse investment is on
hold there is an atmosphere of total
indecision and ineffectiveness at the
heart of government because let's be
frank
there is no parliamentary majority for
what this government is threatening to
do and because this government is
completely obsessed with the
preposterous idea we should loo leave
Europe without a deal the whole of the
agenda for running this country for
modernizing this country is on hold you
what you might talk about it being a
preposterous agenda I spoke to the the
new chancellor Sajid Javid just a couple
of days ago he is in office he's in the
Treasury he has all the briefing notes
about the possible implications of a no
deal-breaker and he says he's not
frightened he's not worried about the
implications he should know shouldn't he
do do you have any reason to actually
doubt him well I think he should start
listening to all the professional
advisers around him and they're telling
him not to worry that's what he says
here that's what he says but we all know
from the very wide extensive press
reporting for all the surveys of
international and financial
expertise that actually the situation is
serious and the idea that you've got a
government which is crashing money
around the place like there's no
tomorrow
aim very specifically at very clear
electoral targets is actually a policy
of economic irresponsibility you talked
about in your op-ed about Dominic
Cummings the advisors the prime minister
being a revolutionary menace what do you
mean by that I mean they've always been
special advisors I think we took I think
we took the words from himself I think
he sees himself as the revolutionary but
let's be frank much more important the
point about having a prime minister and
a cabinet is that they're accountable to
Parliament we've got this guy who is now
in direct contact with the British media
briefing them on policies scathingly
attacking members of the House of
Commons who should be held in respect
and actually parading himself as the
mastermind behind the government that is
an intolerable position for democracy it
is absolutely central that Parliament
should be able to call to account people
who represent them as ministers and at
the moment we are now being told by a
particular figure who's proud of it that
he's more or less sort of running the
show but Lord has owned one of the
things that Parliament has done is to
vote for article 50 and one of the up
sorts of article 50 I mean it's maybe
they're in the small print but
nonetheless it is very much there is
that if there is no deal then the UK
would leave at the end of the deadline
so Palmer has actually voted why don't
process them no no no no when we did the
referendum it was clearly stated by the
leave campaign that they were not going
for no deal in March of this year
Michael Gove clearly said that they did
not want a no deal there is no says
there will be a no deal if there is no
deal you know if there is a deadline and
if there's nothing is reached by that
there is no deal that is part of the
process of leaving well that is not what
Parliament voted for and is quite clear
that Parliament will not
vote for that there is no majority in
parliament and no majority in the
country for No Deal let's talk about
your position within the Conservative
Party you had the whip withdrawn around
the time of the European elections when
you said that you were going to vote for
the Lib Dems have you had the the whip
reinstated since then but I got sacked
by the Prime Minister because I voted
some time ago that Parliament should be
given a meaningful vote at that time the
Prime Minister was arguing that it
shouldn't three weeks later she was
forced by Parliament to concede that
what I had been sacked for advocating
became government policy and so let's be
quite clear that this is a battle which
has been going on and is very intense
ever since the result of the referendum
and it will continue to go on and it
will vitally be fought in Parliament at
the moment Parliament is deadlocked how
the government gets past that isn't
matter we have to see I'm just the
reason I asked about the whip is I'm
just curious as to as to whether you are
kind of now formally still part of the
government's benches on on the Lord's or
whether that's changed my position is
very clear I have stood for the
Conservative Party and fought for it
since the 1950s I have supported every
Prime Minister in one way or another
throughout that period and all of them
were people who argued that Britain's
destiny lay at the heart of Europe I
haven't changed my mind and I will
continue to stay in that position within
the Conservative Party I am a
Conservative Party have fought its most
entrenched battles and will continue to
do so but I will never sacrifice British
self-interest for narrow party purposes
we're talking about the Conservative
Party I mean the polls when you look at
them now there has been a bounce since
Boris Johnson took over it looks like
actually there are a lot of people who
rather support his position on brexit I
mean some people would say actually this
is a good moment for the Tory Party and
in a sense that you're just going
against the grain of that well you
should
look at the Brecon by-election you
should look at the mail on Sunday poll
today showing what's happening in key
marginals where the Lib Dems are seconds
which shows actually there have been no
bounce at all and this is before we've
even got into the serious consequences
of the no brexit risks as that
deteriorates I think people will become
increasingly apprehensive of where this
policy is leading us we shall see but in
the end there is no parliamentary
majority and therefore I don't believe
that Beck's it can happen on a No Deal
basis Prime and a prime minister is one
of 650 people the only thing that
singles them out is that they can
command a majority in the House of
Commons if they can't they're just one
of 650 and that I suspect is the
position in which mr. Johnson will find
himself with no parliamentary majority
and it would be abuse of our
constitution to then think that you can
take Britain out of Europe despite the
House of Commons one of the consequences
of that lack of a majority is that there
was a lot of talk now about the
possibility of a snap election
potentially very soon in the event of a
snap election who would you vote for
well I don't have a vote but that is a
cop-out and I'm saying it before you say
it I can tell you that large numbers of
conservatives and again the poll I
referred to shows that in today's
newspapers will not vote for a No Deal
brexit they will vote for whatever party
appears to stand behind a European
policy the large numbers of
conservatives friends of mine colleagues
of mine approached me every day
asserting the fact that they will vote
for Britain's national self-interest
despite the loyalty they feel to the
Conservative Party and so what would you
what would you advocate for them I will
not myself determine who anyone should
vote for but my view remains that
whatever I may think
large numbers of people will vote for
what they believe to be Britain's
national self-interest and therefore for
a candidate that represents the European
destiny to which this country has been
committed since the 1960s what I wonder
do you think the solution is for this a
lot of people would say that another
second referendum which you've been
advocating would only make the sense of
social cohesion in this country even
worse what is the solution here is there
any neat exit that you would be happy
with well I would be happy with a
solution that leaves Britain at the
heart of Europe of course that is my
position and of every Conservative
leader I've worked for but we are where
we are and I agree with you that the
most likely scenario today is continued
uncertainty but in the event of
continued uncertainty the worst thing to
do is to add to that uncertainty by
actually cutting the ground form
underneath our economic strength which
depends in huge measure on our
membership of the European community